it was back to Brussels with a bump for
mep s this week as they return to an
annual ritual member states national
budgets and the e use process of making
sure they stick to their budget deficit
targets especially those that are
received a bailout and especially now as
the EU is beginning to show wafer-thin
signs of economic recovery the president
of the Eurogroup your own de Sol bloom
arrived to brief any Peas after the
summer break on recommendations that the
EU would be making to get the eurozone
to keep their 2014 deficits under
control we will carefully monitor
measures to rectify imbalances in
countries where excessive economic
imbalances have been found at the same
time I think we've all seen that of the
last half year the European Commission
has allowed countries more and more time
in specific circumstances due to the
economic recession mr. de slow Bloom
said the crisis had been deeper and
tougher to deal with than anyone
expected but pointed to promising shoots
of growth some m eps took him to task
for failing to get debt jobs and growth
forecasts right others warned it was far
too early to be optimistic the global
economy in particular the Western world
is still on a debt bubble private and
public the debt bubble has not
diminished significantly and therefore
the crisis is not over it will pop up
here and there again and political
optimism I would be careful with very
careful if you're Greek protests in
Greece against swingeing austerity
measures refused to die down there's
talk also of another bailout next year
despite some hopeful if modest economic
improvements many MEP support holding
the course thanks to this austerity to
the eurozone and single currency is a
credible currency and we have to
continue with every firms and secondly I
think we have to do whatever needed to
maintain greece in the your son and
super greece the coming months will be
defining in europe a test of whether a
eurozone united in its approach can
capitalize on the first signs of
improvement to appear for years